we have nasa space launch system and
orion spacecraft out on historic launch
pad 39b the launch window opens in less
than 24 hours that's very exciting to
say it's going to be humanity's first
step in going back to the moon
good morning and thank you for joining
us live here at kennedy space center i'm
megan cruz with nasa communications
liftoff of this first uncrewed flight
test is currently targeted for monday
tomorrow august 29th with a two-hour
launch window that opens at 8 33 a.m
eastern time this briefing is to update
you all on how the countdown is going so
far our launch team got on console
yesterday morning and the countdown to
launch started exactly at 10 23 a.m
eastern time here to take your questions
are jeff spalding artemis one senior
nasa test director
and and we have melody levin launch
weather officer with the u.s space force
good morning good morning to you guys
all right so let's kick things off with
opening remarks jeff all right thank you
very much well i am very happy to be
back here again uh for the artemis one
launch countdown l minus one uh status
brief uh we've had a really good day on
our first day of the launch countdown
yesterday we picked up
the count right on time at 9 53 and we
started our clock at 10 23 in the
morning
since that time
we've been working
really hard we got the vehicles powered
up and have been doing testing
throughout the day and evening
as we worked along
we did yesterday you may have seen we
had some
i would call them kind of spectacular
amazing events as we do every day here
in florida some lightning things happen
um we'll go ahead and mention that up
front
we did have some strikes that we
recorded on our tower lightning tower
with the pad working as it nominally
should um and we did
have those we've been evaluating those
through yesterday and through last night
and everything to date it looks very
good from a vehicle perspective we
haven't had to do any significant retest
we have a
threshold that we look at to see what
the magnitude of these strikes are and
we did not meet that criteria to have to
do intensive or invasive uh type retest
so well we did we're able to work all of
that yesterday very cleanly with our
team
and
our management team did approve last
night
that as well uh those occurred yesterday
afternoon at about um third one 1 14 or
so in the afternoon with another couple
events at 1 16.
so uh so far everything looks really
good and as i mentioned we have uh gone
through and
and worked all of the
evaluations that are normally done when
we do have these type of lightning
events um and hopefully we won't have
any today but we understand the weather
we'll be talking about that here next
and we'll see what's going to what
that's going to bring us
we did to do a little bit of re-test
which included we did some canary
circuit checks which are really just
those circuits are there to provide it
if they've seen any what type of voltage
or things that might affect the vehicles
those were all good we did some walk
downs and then we did the analysis with
our
our system experts um as far as of all
the data and and what those lightning
events were so
bottom line is we look really good no
issues no concerns or constraints from
the lightning events at this point
let's see so far i did mention we
powered up yesterday
later in the afternoon or last night we
did power up the rf systems on all of
the vehicles on orion on the core stage
on icps did those checkouts and tests
those all went really well we finished
those
into the early hours of the morning this
morning
we did also work our engine final preps
on the course stage yesterday got
through all of those and again those
finished early last
this morning as well about one o'clock
in the morning we've done the battery
charging on both orion and the core
stage those are complete
so that's all going really well and all
as planned and on schedule
we did
we are currently pressurizing our helium
tanks on the core stage and configuring
some of the umbilicals we've looked
ahead at the weather we know we're going
to probably get something later this
afternoon uh we did have quite a bit of
work planned on second shift tonight
we're pulling some of that in to try to
get that those events going on some of
the pad facility closeouts and and some
of the configurations that we do on uh
some water systems and elevators and
some of those other things so uh we are
trying to be very proactive looking
ahead and evaluating those things and
adjusting as required knowing that we
might get some some weather as as we
have the last few days
um let's see uh we are going to continue
uh later today with some of the orion
checkouts on uh and some of the health
checks that we do on those those are
just standard and normal
that we do
as we get into this tonight we will be
working towards cryo load and the first
part of that is getting on gn2 and
inerting the vehicle we're working those
preps late later second shift tonight
at about 9 45 or so we'll be flowing gn2
to the to the vehicle to inert it to get
ready for a cryoload uh later um
when we get back in um after to get done
with that sorry um we will clear the pad
at about 8 30 tonight to
anticipation of the safe and arm of
device rotations that we do which are
normal plan things that we do before we
get into cryoload
and that'll happen at about 10 30 and
then we'll enter our two and a half hour
built-in hold at 10 53 tonight
i think we've talked a few times that we
did extend it quite a while back from
where it was um previously but it's two
and a half hours starting then um
towards the end of that hole at 11 53
tonight we're expecting to get a go from
the launch director and mmt if
everything looks good and they've
evaluated all the criteria and and we
are going to be go for cryoload that's
the timing that we would be looking for
to uh to get that and then we would
start the cryoload operations at that
time with some of our valve
configurations getting ready to flow
cryos
we start on the liquid oxygen side and
then a little bit later
about an hour and a half or so we start
on the hydrogen side on the core stage
and work through that once core stage is
done then we fill the upper stage
as well throughout the night
we do have the pre-press test test
excuse me scheduled for about 5 40 a.m
uh that test shouldn't take us too long
i think it's been talked a couple of
times um but it's
a test that actually is um
we do during the terminal part account
and we're just going to do it a little
bit early just to get some and evaluate
the data there and the performance of
the valve the valving as well so we can
kind of pre-select the positions of some
of those valves as we get into terminal
count so that'll help us out a little
bit there
we have some uh
final guidance system aligns that we'll
be working as we're doing tanking as
well we power up the range safety
systems to do some final checkouts about
two hours or so prior to launch we'll
work all through those as per our normal
timelines um we'd also have some of our
final vehicle and ground configs that
we'll do once we get to the hole there's
a hold at t minus 10 minutes it's 30
minutes long
that picks up at about 7 53
we do anticipate the opening of the
window and hitting that at 8 33 a.m we
have a two-hour window on our first day
if for some reason we do have to use
subsequent days the plan our nominal
plan is to go on the 5th
the opening of that window is at 12 48
local time and excuse me the second is
the first opportunity sorry it's four
days um turn around and then the next
opportunity will be on the fifth um at
17 12 which is 5 12 in the afternoon
so
that's kind of where we are it's been a
really good first day of the launch
countdown we're within 24 hours of
launch right now which is
pretty amazing for where we've been on
this journey so
our team right now is uh i will say
super excited and we are prepared for
for anything i think that throws at us
to the four wdrs we've done in the past
really i think have prepared us uh for
the moment we're at now for for
virtually any situation that can come up
um but we are excited the vehicle is
going to be ready it's ready right now
looks great and to proceed with this
inaugural launch of the uh the artemis
program
thank you thank you sounds like we're in
a good spot thank you for that update
all right melody how's the weather
well the weather's pretty decent this
morning but of course i will talk about
the forecast for launch a little bit
later first i'm going to talk about
today so let's go ahead and toss it off
to the satellite imagery
and as we look at satellite this morning
you can see some remnant showers and a
leftover thunderstorm or two from last
night's activity that rolled through
late in the day
also as we creep forward in time as we
get to around 10 or 11 o'clock this
morning
just like yesterday we'll start to see
some of those showers and
possible thunderstorms forming along the
east coast something different has
changed today which we were expecting we
do have southeasterly flow in place this
morning and that will remain the case
for tomorrow morning's launch attempt as
well uh so one thing with that will
benefit us today is even though we're
likely going to get rain just like we
almost always do in the space coast in
in august and september uh the east
coast sea breeze will creep farther
across the interior central portion of
the state and
hopefully will give us a large block of
time of clearing this afternoon we may
be examining the chance for some late
night showers and maybe a thunderstorm
or two somewhere across interior florida
but most of the convective activity
should be done for when we're looking to
tank later on tonight
and with that we'll go ahead and move on
to the launch forecast for tomorrow
morning it's a pretty similar outlook
from what i had yesterday but i'm kind
of slicing and dicing it for you
basically the beginning of the launch
window or just after 8 30 in the morning
has a 80 percent chance of favorable
weather as we creep forward in time
through the two-hour launch window
we just have a better chance of some of
those offshore showers and maybe a
thunderstorm or two creeping closer to
the coastline and also because across
the spaceport we're likely to have some
billowing clouds form as we get into 10
o'clock in the 11 o'clock time frame in
the late morning hours
so
as usual or just just like yesterday i
do not have a backup forecast for you
because that is a five-day forecast now
i will have those estimates for you
tomorrow if they are needed for the
backup launch window
the one thing to note though is the
forecast is largely going to depend on
the evolution of the tropics and also
the time of day
is going to be a contributing factor
the time of day for the backup launch
window is around
noon to 2 pm ish time frame when in
general you can expect a higher
probability of violation for weather
just because we're likely to have those
showers and storms forming along the
coastline during that time frame
so with that i think that concludes my
brief i'll toss it back thank you so
much thanks for that refined look at the
at the launch window uh so we'll take
questions now you know the drill in the
room raise your hands and we'll try to
get a mic to you and then we also have
some people on the phone uh hit star one
to get yourself into the question queue
okay so we'll start with marcia over
there marcia done ap for jeff um so
there was no residual effects impact to
even any of the ground equipment from
the lightning strikes and when you first
saw the video or pictures of that like
were you all so worried that you know
this is it there goes our try and and
lastly brand new rocket
[Music]
what what's your take on whether it's
really going to take off tomorrow
whether on you know aside
all right a lot of questions um
so uh we we have tested a lot of
including our ground systems we went
back in and looked at those and we've
also walked them down um as we do when
there are lightning strikes that and we
get to certain levels just to make sure
there's nothing um beyond what we can
see via the data
that we may have missed and so that's
what we have done and the systems went
out and did that yesterday during the
day as well on top of that we haven't
seen anything on the ground systems that
gives us any concern nor on any of the
vehicle
as well um i would say whenever we see
things that are as dramatic as lightning
right we all we pay a lot of attention
to it as we should and so we that just
for us kicks us off into the next
mode for us to go and evaluate what
happened we just i i'd say we've seen it
enough through the uh the processing
flows that we just do and and are not
that we're comfortable with it but that
we are definitely um well rehearsed at
the process by which we go and collect
the data look at the data see what we
need to do from a vehicle and ground
system perspective and then move on from
there and then evaluate whether we have
to do more after we've done all of those
initial data collects and that's where
we got to yesterday and got through all
the initial parts and then we looked
good at that point so
and i would say
my thoughts are that we look great for
tomorrow
love the fact that the weather looks
really like it's going to cooperate in
the beginning of the window and and our
job is to get to the beginning of the
window and that's what i'm going to try
to get the team to do
thank you irene
irene klotz with aviation week
yesterday we were briefed about some
communications reconfigurations that
needed to be retested in orion
what was the status of that and what was
changed and why was it changed
um there were a couple of uh different
parameters that
when our jsc flight control team
when we do our com checkouts and those
types of things they have a command
window in which they upload um
parameters that we need for for guidance
and a whole lot of other things that um
during that time frame there were a
couple of items that we saw late on the
com system that needed to be changed and
that it just goes in as part of that
upload to the vehicle that occurred and
so i would say it's it's in the normal
process for us to be able to do that and
that's what they were able to do as well
we can probably get some more specific
data about the data parameters
themselves if you if you need that but
what we can say is that we did complete
that part of it and right now everything
looks good
so are there any outstanding issues at
all
there's no issues with that right now i
meant in general beyond the comms text
the only thing that we're looking at
this morning um is um
and we're not even out of uh out of spec
is on our um helium provider that's at
the ccf uh last night the the helium
supply pressures were a little bit low
so they have a vendor coming out to look
at that
they think they may have a small leak
again it's within the band that we need
to support us for launch but they want
to make sure that we're in the best
configuration we can be for that system
since we use a fair amount of helium on
this rocket and so that's one of the
things we're looking at this morning to
see if there's something that needs to
be done and those folks will be on
actually should be on station now
over there hi good morning tom costello
with nbc news uh two quick questions
jeff i heard you say a few and then i
counted was a two lightning strikes or
more than two that you had on the five
events that were evaluated um that
got to the threshold that we needed to
go and look at and evaluate them uh they
happen in fairly rapid succession
sometimes these events that occur
and when these when the events are we
have monitoring devices at the pad
on the ml and the pad itself that
collect data and then we go back and
evaluate those data there was five of
those
items that we looked at
to evaluate whether it was going to be a
concern from the vehicle as far as the
magnitude or anything out to that effect
and that only got us to the criteria to
go and take a look at the systems that
we did and it was not at such a
magnitude that we needed to go and do
anything beyond that there was no it was
well within or or not had not even come
close to the existence of what those
requirements were two more very quick
ones number one do you anticipate that
the helium the tiny small helium leak
could become a show stopper that's
number one number two uh you cannot am i
correct you don't tolerate rain at all
for a launch you would not launch with
rain at all is that correct
so there is a fly-through rain
constraint
melody could probably speak to it better
than than i since they're responsible
for uh for those lccs as well
but and i'll let her answer when i'm
done and then the first one was on the
helium
right now again we're with intolerance
on being able to support us for launch
this would be to get us even more uh
tolerance on that as well so we're we're
looking at it i don't expect it to be um
if anything they might go in and
re-torque um a flange or something like
that i don't but beyond that no idea if
we're gonna have to do anything else
we have one question here and then we'll
go to bell
i i'm rebecca morrell from bbc news um a
few quick questions um the first is how
many seconds before launch do the four
rs 25 engines ignite for the shuttle it
was about five or six seconds before
yeah um oh sorry go ahead several
questions
just the second one is it's down to the
seconds again actually um if you do go
at the start of the launch window are
you aiming for 8 33 exactly or would it
be like 8 33 and 15 seconds or 40
seconds or you know just
how exact is that number if it goes yeah
those are great questions so so the
engines start and it's a staggered start
on the engines um about every 200
milliseconds
in between the the start times on the
engines
but it's about 6.8 seconds when we'll be
starting the engines up and then the
timing for our opening of the window and
our t0 time that we'll be shooting for
in the beginning is exactly at 8330
bill
first of all if you were going to say
something about the weather constrainer
for the fly-through constraint that is
true we there is a constraint we can't
fly through
something we consider precipitation
which if you're a meteorologist we
consider that 18 dbz on the radar um the
the thing about it though is we have to
be flying directly through it there's
not really a standoff distance for that
um so because of that it does buy us
um a decent amount of real estate on the
radar as far as finding the hole in the
clouds for us to launch through so it
and also a lot of times
it has to be right over the pad because
when we launch we launch and we go up
right and we oftentimes fly over these
low clouds that have rain
so hopefully that answers your question
bottom line is it's not 100
you can't fly through any rain
correct yes
uh bill harwich cbs news um jeff well
two quick ones for me um for the record
the helium is on the ground side i'm
assuming yes not in the sea it's on the
supply side on the facility side yeah um
you know you've done a lot of shuttle
countdowns back in the day and this is a
this is a very similar uh countdown from
shuttle except you know the quantities
are different things like that what are
the two or three things you're looking
forward to
uh and i won't use the word concern but
what are the things if you had to rank
things that you really want to get past
this milestone that milestone what are
you looking for tonight when you're on
console
so okay the the first things i look at
are the things that melody is concerned
about weather right because that gets us
either we can either get into tanking or
not i think i feel really good about
tonight us getting into tanking and
getting through that um the only things
that we're looking at really during the
count is we've had hydrogen leaks you
know in some of the wet dress rehearsals
we've done our best to mitigate all of
the concerns with those with a lot of
changes to the um the boots and to the
lines into this to a lot of different
things we've changed some of our um
evaluation criteria to give us more
flexibility on what we can do so that
part gives us a little bit of uh um
something that we look at and that as we
go through and we kind of evaluate
and then the rest of it is just
everything else right we need to be on
time
it's been difficult for a number of
reasons as we've run through the uh the
wet dress rehearsals to get through all
of the work with the constraints the
great thing is we have done
an outstanding job addressing each and
every one of those things that have
caused us concern or delayed us for the
reasons that we've had through those
countdowns and so we've got a lot of
practice behind us we've put those
things behind us and addressed each and
every one so going into this i feel like
we are in the best possible
configuration we could be to get to
launch on launch day so i feel that part
i feel really good about it
all right we're going to go to two on
the phone we have stephen clark space
flight now
hi thank you stephen clark space flight
now
what are if any what are the weather
constraints for proceeding into
prohibition and tanking tonight
the constraints for tanking tonight are
mostly a temperature constraint that
would
we wouldn't even approach it because
it's very cold and
also we have to have less than a 20
percent chance of lightning to tank
and that's a determination that
my tanking lo mark burger would make
tonight
thank you steven we also have a wreak
malek space.com on the phone
uh yes hello this is uh tarek malek with
space.com and i think my question is for
jeff this is the first flight of a new
rocket i'm just wondering if there's
um anything special you're planning to
tell the team before you really get into
the the final phase of the countdown or
a little commemoration uh you know how
how do you plan to kick things off
tonight
this is a special it will be a special
day tomorrow it is every day really for
uh for artemis as we've been able to get
into the launch countdown um
our team has been excited for a really
long time about what they're doing and
and what the way in which they're
supporting this program and and our
ability to get back to the moon and put
people on the moon and so
i we get to work with a lot of folks
that are a lot younger than me these
days i've been around for a while um and
to see their faces and to hear the their
voices and the excitement that they have
each and every day because we ask a lot
of folks as a lot of the programs do um
to get us to this point and they've done
an outstanding job
we will talk to him a little bit i know
when i come on console i'm going to walk
around the firing room and talk to folks
um a little bit and uh and and share
some of our uh our stories that we can
as we before we get i get on console and
we get into the terminal part without
disrupting them obviously too much from
what they're doing
i would expect that we'll probably have
some words towards the end as we're
getting ready for the poll or coming out
of that as well so there might be some
words there but i don't have to do
anything to to get this team motivated
or to get them prepared they have done
an outstanding job getting themselves in
that position and we're ready to go
here in the front row oh great thank you
ken kramer space up close thanks for
doing all this my question is for jeff
um going back to the lightning
protection system so this was a moderate
weak strike what if it had been strong
like the really strongest strike that
this could withstand would you have had
enough time
to to evaluate the system or would that
have caused the delay and i'm also
wondering if you're thinking about any
upgrades to the lightning protection
system uh after this launch thanks
so
uh
the lightning evaluation process if we
meet our threshold criteria involves
certain levels of retest we have a panel
that makes recommendations on that based
on the criteria that's been developed
and then those come forward to
management
some of those take quite a bit of time
we can get the times for you it would
have been um a challenge we may not have
had to do all of them again it is very
dependent upon
the size the magnitude and all the other
things that we would have seen on our
triggers as what we may or may not have
had to do so
it's really difficult to say whether
there would have been a delay clearly
the system worked as designed and uh and
so did the processes to do the
evaluation gather the data and make a
concerted effort to uh to make a
decision which we got to yesterday and
then last night the management decision
to accept the data that we saw and
re-test or the evaluations that we did
yesterday with the canary circuits and
some of the other things that we did on
the vehicle so i think that part worked
i can't speak to the
the lightning tower designs because i'm
not sure where we are with those um
again they're working
pretty well as they
have thus far i don't seem to think that
we
would need anything but i can't speak to
that i need to get somebody else to
answer that for you
we'll go to gym and then we have these
two in the front row after
hi i'm jim siegel i'm with
nasatech.net
and i have a question about
commercial and military aircraft that
might be in the air about the time of
the of the launch so i assume that
there's some sort of requirement for
commercial aircraft uh not being in the
air or in the area
and i wondered what what exactly that
criteria was i also wondered whether any
nasa or any military
aircraft are going to be
around to
to witness this
this launch as it happens thank you
so we do work with the faa to provide
airspace clears during the times of
launch
no different than any other
vehicle coming off of the range has to
do for their launches as well so that
happens and we've been working with them
for an extended period of time
um
military etcetera all we have uh
notice to airmen and and other things
for all types of aircraft that may or
may not be in the area so we work very
closely with them do the same thing for
the waters as well
i probably won't go into what the
clear space and some of those things are
from just from a
security posture but but we do have all
of those things lined up um and to
support us we will have an aircraft in
the air that does um that has filming
analysis that they do our wb-57 is
airborne and they'll be out there we
have another aircraft that's going to be
doing some shadowing uh
data gathering as well that's up there
so all the aircraft that are in the air
approved and uh and part of our apps
plan for the through the aircraft and
those are the ones that are allowed into
the airspace the rest of us controlled
thank you
hi denise vickers from wuft at the
university of florida in gainesville um
uh my question is for melody
specifically for people who aren't at
the cape how far can we anticipate
people can see
artemis lifting off for example will our
listeners and readers and viewers in
gainesville be able to see a fireball
so give me some sort of sense of how far
across the state will be able to see it
i'm not sure exactly
but i will say you will see more of a
fireball with this one than you would
see with any of the recent launches that
we've had
because shuttle you could see it very
far away
it is a daytime launch not a nighttime
launch and of course at night the the
light travels a little bit farther you
know in the darkness so
i think you'll probably be able to see
it from there i have friends in tampa
that usually can see
something in general so with this i
think you'd have a better shot in
gainesville
hi jacob sadessi also from wuft news um
so obviously you all have been talking
about all these pre-flight preparations
that have been going on in this last
countdown to launch
how different is that process going to
be when there are actually people on
board is this process that you're going
through right now going to be pretty
similar to what it's going to be like
when the craft is actually manned or
is it going to be a little bit different
is it a little bit looser than it would
be
so
the difference is
will primarily be related to the crew
activities um as they were coming out
the
the process for preparing the pad for
launch is the same the process preparing
the vehicle for launch is the same our
loading of the cryogenics will all be
the same from that perspective the only
difference which isn't related to the
crew
is the fact that we will have a new
sphere and one of the larger sphere for
the the next launch that gives us more
capability storage capability for
hydrogen um to allow us to have a 24
hour turnaround that's different so we
will have a little bit different loading
process um not sure if that's going to
extend or not the timing for that we'll
do that because we will do a test to
verify that
the crew time will add about two hours
is our estimate at this point because we
don't have the crew yet and and all the
systems uh figured out from an ops
perspective on how long it's going to
take to do that but it's about two
additional hours on the countdowns
meaning the tanking would start earlier
by about two hours or so based on what
we know today
i'm going to go to one on the phone and
then i am tracking three in the room
here so the one on the phone is marvin
marshall from the nighttime news space
report
hi my name is marvin marshall from
nighttime news space report here on
twitch.tv i appreciate you guys taking
my question my questions for melody at
what time eastern time will you be
pretty certain uh you know to call a go
on on launch today for those you know
couple primary weather constraints that
you're worried about thank you
it's really going to depend on the
evolution of the shower coverage
offshore um
i think around 5 a.m will be the pivotal
time because we'll we'll really see what
we're dealing with usually around that
time frame we see the max of the
offshore land breezes colliding
and and we'll be able to see what kind
of showers we already have out there and
we'll be able to track
them moving towards the space coast
during that time frame
of course if we push later into the
window we'll have to adjust that time
frame a little bit but 5 am will
probably be a pivotal time for us
thank you marvin all right over here in
the room
for afp news agency i just want to
double check something from the briefing
uh yesterday that charlie said if
tanking doesn't happen
for the launch window on the second she
said launch could happen on the third
i'm just wondering um
if tonight the tanking for weather
concerns uh doesn't happen could the
launch be tomorrow
so yeah well i i think you mean on the
30th if you could jump a day um so right
now we don't have um launch
opportunities
on the 30th the first
the 30th or 31st and the first so our
next opportunity would be the second
um
so and if you need more clarification on
the other let me know but
i think we're good
i'm john bisney with university florida
press uh maybe a question for megan can
you tell us where the vice president
will be watching the launch from and
would you expect her to speak to the
team after the fire in the firing room
if you have a successful launch
uh yes i believe the vice president will
be watching from nearby here at the
press site and then i think the plan is
to hopefully have her speak uh at the
lcc and we'll try to bring that to you
live on the launch broadcast
okay and then over here in the front row
oh over here
[Music]
uh hi eric berger with rs technica two
questions weather related first of all i
think for jeff
this is a test flight obviously are
there different weather constraints for
this mission
then you would have down the line are
you gonna be able to sort of close the
windows of constraints on launch as you
sort of get more experience flying the
system and then maybe for melody you
know talking about those launch windows
later on where you get in the afternoon
evening and you get those florida storms
like if you were launching today at 12
48 or excuse me tomorrow 12 40 instead
of 8 33
would the confidence be like 40 50
percent of favorable conditions or and i
know you can't give a precise answer but
maybe just talk a little bit about that
thank you
for most of that question to melody but
um our launch criteria for weather is
pretty much the same for when whenever
we're going to launch and and so it'll
be pretty standard for
there's not a lot of changes that will
be
initiated based on you know different
dates or times in which we we would
launch
so i don't know if you wanted to add
anything to the what lcc part but yeah
that is correct um i think mostly our
weather constraints will be the same
the one thing that would not be included
in the pov the probability of violation
um that we would just also be tracking
is maybe just watching more recovery
weather
the marine environment in case the
astronauts need to for some reason abort
or anything like that
and could you repeat the second part of
your oh the the timing of the day um
yeah i think 40 to 50
for probably a conservative 40 to 60
would probably be
a good estimate during that time frame
especially with this weak flow that we
have
you've we've seen a lot of showers pop
up during that time frame but they don't
move inland very fast
and of course that's due to the weak
flow so it really depends on exactly
where the showers are forming and it's
really not also just about showers it's
about how tall the clouds are before
they even produce the precipitation so
um in general yeah that it would be that
mid-grade
probability of violation during that
time
another question in the back of the room
there thanks um good morning dan shaffer
with way 31 in huntsville alabama just a
couple of questions from melody if you
could be more specific about how you're
going to be monitoring the weather
up to
launch time
uh is it just radar satellite are you
sending balloons up a lot and how often
and are there planes flying up and how
are you monitoring all the winds and
things and also taking a look at the
weather this morning in the cloud cover
would this
violate launch criteria as it sits
great question so we have a lot we have
many different ways of tracking the
weather pretty much everything you
listed is the way we're tracking the
weather we have our own radar we also
have we also utilize this national
weather service melbourne's backup radar
as well as all the other national
weather service radars
nearby across the state
to monitor
the the showers and the the clouds that
are forming our radar specifically is
tuned to
locate where the cloud edges are whereas
weather service is more attuned to
different things severe weather
but yes we're also sending up balloons
we also have something called
t-drip and we also have the 915
megahertz radars that are sensing the
low-level boundary movement of the winds
we have a nasa supply jet that we can
fly out to any concerning clouds to see
exactly where the cloud edges are in
case we're wondering if they're
violating or going to violate so
and we also have a merlin lightning
system that we use to track any cloud to
cloud or cloud to ground lightning
that is occurring so we have we have all
the tools uh to watch that kind of
situation and uh could you remind me of
the second part of your question
right now yes you launched with this
kind of cloud cover um i'd have to look
at it specifically but i believe that
even though a lot of those showers and
thunderstorms are lingering along i
think it is farther away than 10
nautical miles from the flight path
so i think we would be okay of course i
don't have radar specifically in front
of me right right now but i think we'd
be fine and the the good news is a lot
of these showers at night follow the
warm waters of the gulf stream and
exactly where pad 39b is it's kind of in
that sheltered area of the cooler waters
of course we are in summer so a lot of
the waters are warm anyway but it is a
little bit of a shelter for the pad
that corner
hi lauren gresh with bloomberg i'm
wondering if you could clarify further
those blackout dates you were talking
about i believe yesterday charlie said
there were other opportunities to launch
that weren't just the second perhaps we
misunderstood some of us thought that
maybe there was an option to launch
during those blackout dates can you just
confirm that you cannot launch on those
dates if we don't launch on monday right
now yeah the 8 29 tomorrow is our first
opportunity the next one after that's
the second
between the second and the fifth there
are opportunities available which i
think charlie was alluding to
and
for example if we did not tank for
example on the second for some reason
we could potentially like maybe weather
we could potentially come back the next
day and try again because that is a day
if in fact we got the range and all the
other things lined up for us to be able
to do that so there are other dates if
we tank however
we we have to take hydrogen to replenish
the quantities that we've used and that
doesn't get us to the next day so it's
there's a lot to unpack and all of that
but that would then put us to the fifth
because we have to replenish and bring
in tankers to replenish our hydrogen
okay
and we have marsha and then irene
marcia dnap jeff five events mean five
strikes at the pad is that
uh
lightning-wise is that what you meant
five lightning strikes at the pad these
are the trigger the these are the uh
record we recorded five events on the
monitoring system that we evaluated yes
so events meaning strikes yes okay and
if the
strike and melody can correct me if i'm
wrong can produce multiple events
because it doesn't it's not just one
stroke there's a lot of other things
that can come off of the individual
stroke
and if for some reason the engines
ignite and then abort right
do you have to replace those engines and
obviously roll back into the pad to do
that or not and what kind of a hit would
that take
um to do the whatever you need to do to
get back for your next attempt yeah the
the plan is to if in fact they were the
case where we had an engine shut down we
would do the normal um operations to get
off the pad and come back to the to the
vab we would be looking to change out
those engines that's the quickest path
uh to get us back to flight and
the actual amount of days i
i i don't want to give you an actual
number we i know we have that so i think
we can owe that to you and then we can
get that number
i just don't have it exactly in front of
me
yes
and and then also we'd have to look at
then where we line up with our launch
periods because we don't have all days
in the months ahead so there's there's a
lot of things that would have to be
evaluated once we get to that point
okay irene
thanks um
has nasa already talked to the 45th
about um launch opportunities on the
third and the third and fourth and is
the sixth in the
in the offing again
so we we have available days that we
have from a vehicle perspective and a
mission and performance perspective that
we can launch in and those are the dates
that you just alluded to
the range is always
has to be negotiated
just because customers can come on and
off the range very quickly as we see
with a lot of the customers that are
here so we would have to have that we've
had conversations to date guys about
those types of things i don't have the
details and how far or what that would
mean
for the range but the range does a great
job of supporting us for for when we've
asked for for support
launch team compared to shuttle and
maybe if you can give us a little flavor
of what it's like to be on this team
with the younger people who may not have
been through shuttle launches um what do
you what do you see is like different
and and what's very much the same
in the launch firing room we have about
90
personnel in there i think it's 91 but
and then in shuttle we had over 200
in in the launch team so it's quite a
different sized team
uh the the fire room layout is different
than it was in shuttle we we did that um
coming into this program so it is a
little bit different and
um it actually is a little bit more
conducive to the way in which we do the
work so that really helps us out
uh the second part of the question was
just the the um
how they
how the team is
working what it feels like to be on this
team with people who have not been
through a shuttle launch or what is very
much the same
um uh with shuttle
so
yeah we we have a a mix right we just
still have some folks that have been
through shuttle not as many as we used
to right quite quite a few less so that
helps to
uh at least try to give some guidance to
the to the folks that are coming up from
an experienced level to get their own
flavor of what to expect because they
haven't been through it and they they're
very wide-eyed and and doing again a
fantastic job we have some
extremely smart people that have come up
very quickly through the ranks to to get
the positions that they now hold in the
firing room uh doing their launch commit
criteria so that part has been really
good um from a team perspective
and i and i think it's
to me it's it's different but it's a lot
of it is the same the way in which we
run countdowns
still is pretty much the same way as
what we have in the past our
expectations are high the demand on the
team is is also high but the performance
is also extremely high from the people
that are in the room and we have trained
and trained to get them to the level
so that they would be ready to support
this launch countdown and everybody has
to have a first one right and this is
going to be the first for for a great
number of people in that room
great question okay we have ken and then
eric and then bill sorry it's up close
thank you i'd like to follow up to what
i think you just said to the colleague
about an ignition abort
you said you have to roll back
the rocket if you have an ignition
aboard and swap out the engines uh why
is that
so opposed to just evaluating that
there's a number of things that have to
and
these engines are very similar to what
we had in in in shuttle as you recall
but there are a lot of number of
inspections and other things that have
to happen that are intrusive to the
engines themselves um
and
we may still have opportunities to to do
this at the pad but i don't think that
we do in no where would we want to
but we roll back to do it it actually
takes less time
we have other engines that are available
for other missions to swap engines out
than it does to go back and disassemble
them and do the intrusive inspections
and then get them back to a functional
thing through the testing after we put
them back together to make sure that
we're ready to go and and use them again
so that's the part that that happens
they're reusable engines but there is we
do make sure that there's no issues or
other concerns because we just had a an
engine aboard for some reason right and
so we're going to go back and make sure
that we understand exactly what happened
and that it's not across all of the the
fleet and those type of things
so there's no chance
that you would just be able to evaluate
them
and then roll back out without swapping
them out
so that i probably can't answer that
question because i never
like to uh answer absolutes like i just
did
so uh i don't think that i think that i
would have to
say that we would go back i didn't give
you that answer
the normal plan would be to go back
you don't want to be at the launch pad
doing that type of work we're talking
about changing out engines and those
type of things
okay eric
a couple questions but
first melody you said you talked about
the tropics which could be coming toward
florida as we get a little bit deeper
into september and you know fourth fifth
sixth time period so i'm wondering
jeff
obviously you're gonna launch
configuration now for the rocket for for
whatever reason it doesn't go off
tomorrow um or on the second
how long does it take you to get out of
launch configuration and roll back to
the vab if you're concerned about
weather
it would take us about three and a half
days
to do that so
you know and we're trying to beat the
weather with the work that we have
because we do have some constraints as
we're doing the role itself and we so
we're trying to do that plus we've got
we got to get off the pad there's a
fair amount of work to be done it's
about three and a half days
bill
uh phil heard again two very very uh
quick ones for me uh is there a visual
tracking requirement for this launch in
other words if you were overcast but
didn't have rain is there anything that
would keep you from going just because
the cameras couldn't see it as it climbs
out is there any kind of rule like that
and and uh jeff remember uh you know
whenever there's gls transition we'd
always hear the lady
tell us that you know and who who is
that person for als transition that we
might hear on the net tomorrow um that's
alex pandelos alex perhaps the smartest
guy i work with in the firing room so i
say that all the time to him um but yeah
he is our gls operator that keeps us on
pace and and keeps the ground launch
sequencer and all the events that are
happening on track
uh weather's not tracking any constraint
for visuals
for any artemis i mean sls launch to be
able to visually see the rocket
the range has requirements on the range
safety side to be able to see the rocket
during certain portions of the flight
in addition we have trackers we have a
lot of other things so when we say see
the rocket there's a lot of ways in
which we can see and track the rocket
through
through all of these different things so
there's a lot in that question when we
we talk about what that means to see it
but whether it's visual or whether it's
other things but there is a visual part
but during the initial part of launch
it's there's a lot of data that we lose
there and so we have actual observers
even that are watching the vehicle in
the very first parts of launch
um because
you lose telemetry and you lose a lot of
things when you come off the pad do the
heating and the other thing so
yeah i know
if you had a heavy overcast but you
didn't have precipitation and there
weren't temperature constraints in that
column could just still launch i guess
that's what we have the cloud rules and
a lot of other things and melody is well
aware of what those issues are um yes we
could still launch as far as i'm
concerned
and i'll take the last question from tom
for the non-rocket scientists among us
other than bill who i think by now is a
rocket scientist um can you explain for
us uh if
if you have to abort uh before you know
you've you've go ahead you've you've
loaded all the cryos and then you have
to abort what's the process for making
the vehicle safe for
bringing down the liquid hydrogen how do
you how do you deal with liquid oxygen
all of that
so if we make a decision that we're
going to scrub we can't go because
something's not working as it is
expected right
that decision is made we would issue a
cutoff to the vehicle which is something
that can happen
automatically in the end when the ground
launch sequencer as we were just talking
about is doing that for us and
monitoring all those things inside of 10
minutes
but that would do the initial part of
our safing and power down some of our
high energy systems if they're powered
up if we haven't gotten inside of 10
minutes a lot most of those are already
down or haven't been initiated yet so
that
that would happen at that point um if we
needed to go in and work that but and
then once we get through the initial
safing the rest of it is just
configuring the valves for drain
if we've tanked all the way we're
continuing to still fill the tank we
call it replenish um because it's always
boiling off right we're losing uh the
liquid hydrogen and oxygen through boil
off because it's so cold and no matter
how well you insulate it it's going to
continue to boil off and we vent that
off and plus we're bleeding some of the
hydrogen off so we we have that
replenished so we kind of stopped that
and then we would start going into drain
and initiate our vent and drain um once
we've secured and saved all of the
systems that are that may have been up
for prior to that time and then we just
drain the vehicle and then it's kind of
working in reverse we open the valves
and the other way we pressurize and send
the commodity back to the tank
okay that'll do it thank you so much for
the questions thank you jeff thank you
melody again the launch window opens in
less than 24 hours tomorrow 8 30 a.m
eastern time so our launch coverage our
live launch broadcast will begin on nasa
tv and our streaming channels at 6 30 am
and then for our spanish audience you
can watch on nasa and espanol's social
media channels starting at 7 30 a.m i
hope you can join us thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you